there is something very interesting
going on and my concern is that it will
simply lead to the re-election of Donald
Trump in November and what I'm talking
about is that many self-described
progressives are turning on longtime
progressive heroes even calling them
sellouts in some cases this has already
been happening with Bernie Sanders since
last week
it is now happening with Noam Chomsky
Noam Chomsky now says that Donald Trump
must be defeated and that Noam Chomsky
will vote for Joe Biden and that this is
just ultra clear to Noam Chomsky and
Chomsky even went as far as to liken the
never Biden people to the enablers of
Nazis from the 1930s referring to
communists who refuse to ally with
Social Democrats against Nazis in
Germany
this is enraging many leftists let's
take a look and then discuss this is
from an interview with Mehdi Hasan let's
listen very carefully to what Noam
Chomsky says what do you make of the
never Biden movement well it also brings
up some memories the early 30s in
Germany the communist party following
the Stalin's line at the time took the
position that everybody but us is a
social fascist so there's no difference
between the Social Democrats and the
Nazis so therefore not we're not going
to join with the Social Democrats to
stop the Nazi plea we know where that
live okay there are many other cases
like this and I think we're seeing a
rerun of it so let's take the position
never buy a mock on a vote survive well
there is such a thing there's a thing
called arithmetic and debate a lot of
things but not arithmetic failure the
hook for Biden in this election in a
swing state amounts to voting for Trump
takes one vote away from the opposition
same as adding one good drum so if you
decide you want to vote
for the destruction of organized human
life on earth for the increase a sharp
increase in threat of nuclear war for
stuffing the judiciary with young
lawyers will make it impossible to do
anything for a generation they do it
openly and with that one video instantly
many who have for decades revered Noam
Chomsky as the standard bearer of
progressivism and leftism are now
relegated to alleging that Noam Chomsky
has sold out that Chomsky is a tool of
the dnc because in the end he ends up
voting for Democrats and a ton of
leftists are throwing Noam Chomsky's
perspective in the trash and we're
seeing something similar with Bernie
himself because remember as soon as
Bernie said last with two weeks ago and
then last week first Bernie said I'm out
then Bernie said I'm endorsing Joe Biden
then Bernie said it would be
irresponsible not to vote for Joe Biden
just as quickly those who three weeks
ago were saying Bernie is the most
genuine trustworthy honest politician
out there are now saying I don't trust
Bernie he's given in to the DNC screw
Bernie I'm never voting for Biden Bernie
has become a tool of the DNC
so this is really important stuff and I
want to break it down in pieces what we
have here are people who have agreed
with Bernie and Chomsky for a long time
on essentially everything saying Bernie
and Chomsky are wrong on this that
doesn't mean that they've always been
wrong and I actually think that that's
fine
that's totally reasonable nobody agrees
with anyone on everything I would be
falling prey to a destructive logical
fallacies if I were to say if you
supported Bernie for a long time you
must agree with Bernie that we have to
vote for Joe Biden that would be a
fallacy for me to say that it would be a
fallacy for me to say if you have for
decades revered Noam Chomsky as the
standard bearer of leftists and leftism
you are wrong - now say Chomsky is wrong
about Biden that would be a logical
fallacy and so I'm not going to do that
but there is a difference between sort
of agreeing and disagreeing on
individual issues versus believing that
someone has at a fundamental level sold
out because of their approach to an
election and what I mean by that is
maybe you agree with Bernie on health
care and you disagree with Bernie about
free college great that fantastic let's
debate policy no problem whatsoever you
might agree with Noam Chomsky on
imperialism
but you might disagree with Noam Chomsky
about education great these are just
simple policy disagreements but that's
not what's going on now and that's what
scares me
because if you agree with Bernie on
issue a and you disagree with Bernie on
issue B many of Bernie's followers like
him because they see him as a genuine
principled trustworthy and honest
elected official in contrast to much of
what is out there - now say when Bernie
says hey we've got it we got a vote
Biden - now say Bernie has sold out and
has collapsed under the pressure of the
DNC or whatever that's not disagreeing
on an issue that's essentially saying
you've misjudged the character of Bernie
all along are you really that bad a
judge of character that you were tricked
by Bernie for years or decades only to
now realize he's sold out as a DNC shill
it's kind of weird
same thing applies to Chomsky saying
Chomsky has become a DNC tool because he
recognizes the importance of removing
Trump that's not I agree with Chomsky on
war but I disagree with Chomsky on
welfare that's saying all along I
believed Tomsky to be something totally
different than what he is on the basis
of saying we've got to remove Trump
Bernie and Chomsky are being realists
they're being harm reducers they're
objectively analyzing the choices it's
down to Biden or Trump and both Bernie
and Chomsky widely trusted and respected
leftist figures have made a choice that
makes sense to them and now people who
revered them for decades are saying
these two are untrust
so either you've been terrible judges of
character about these two all along or
maybe they're still the same people you
believe them to be and as such they're
simply correct that the best move is to
defeat Trump by voting Biden for me it's
clear let's come together and remove
Trump
I'm ready on Twitter let me know where
you disagree I'm deep Ackman on Twitter